[Music]
our product testers come to work just
like anybody else
their
job here though
is problem solving
they're here to put their
backs into it a little bit of elbow
grease
big difference is that they are 600
pound
hungry grizzly
[Music]
bears this is randy he works at the
grizzly and wolf discovery center just
outside the gates of yellowstone
national park when bears become
habituated to human food they often
become dangerous and are either killed
or put into captivity
so to keep bears and people safe
randy runs a program that tests coolers
trash cans and other food storage
containers on live bears
if the containers pass the test they're
given bear resistance certification
[Music]
the bears here at the center are all
rescued bears from the wild these are
bears that gained access to unnatural
unsecured foods and no longer can live
in the wild we have seven grizzly bears
total
they're super super strong they're very
very smart but it's that sense of smell
that really gets them the food reward
their job is to sniff out weaknesses
in products they are the ultimate
testers here at the center
once the product is here we bait the
product with the bear's favorite food
whether it be fish meat peanut butter
honey in a way you could say i'm the
chef for the bears since i'm preparing
their favorite meals to try to entice
the bears to get into those products
if it's a cooler it requires padlocks
put it out in the bear habitat and let
the bears add it
[Music]
once the bears start the testing process
the clock begins
and it's a one hour time frame
that the bears are given in order to try
to gain access to that product
some of the most common techniques the
bears use when they're trying to get in
a product is the the biting the
chewing the clawing yeah a little bit of
smashing but they also do what we call
the cpr method so they're they're
bouncing up and down with their front
paws anything to try to find that weak
point in that product
a lot of times they're going to get a
little hole started and then literally
from there they're tearing the product
apart
so it has to withstand that one hour and
if it passes it then gets that
certification of being bear resistant
this cooler passed the test even though
it got some damage on the top lid they
were not able to get through that outer
layer
all the product testing is videotaped so
the manufacturers they're going to
review that footage
if a product fails the manufacturer is
going to have to go back to the drawing
board and make some changes
that would be a fail
the product testing is open to the
public and hopefully when they leave
here they have a better understanding of
how smart and how strong bears are and
how food driven they are
there is a saying that a fed bear is a
dead bear and it basically means that
when those bears get into unnatural food
sources they're going to be hanging
around our houses and they're more prone
to get into trouble
so working here at the grizzly center
for 20-plus years really have learned to
appreciate and love the bears here and
want to keep the bears out in the wild
where they belong
[Music]
you